video got out about me telling coach
prom I want to go back on the field this
week I need to play this week we need to
get everything we can so I can get back
on the field I'm not taking No for
answers
how did you know that
because what
no
you ain't ready and I care about your
boy and I care about this game you're
going to change the game of football one
day when you help them ready the future
is brighter than mine ever will be it
ever will relax and get healthy I love
you son that was the conversation
I care about y'all more care about this
game but I want you to learn throughout
this game and through our trials and
tribulations who you are it is hard
seeing my teammates my brothers go out
there work and then I know I'm just a
missing piece at the end of the day it's
just hard I just like going out there
and playing at the end of the day I love
team to death man I know one of the
cabinets one of the top dogs and I know
without me it's kind of hard for them to
Just Adjust in one week